[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm Marcus and I'll be your guide today
together we'll walk through some common
scenarios of using the manufacturing
data engine and looker from Google Cloud
using its Market leading Ai and data
products Google Cloud created an
end-to-end solution for processing
contextualizing and storing factory data
the solution leverages key Google Cloud
products including including Cloud
dataflow looker bigquery and Pub sub
for today's demo we've set up a
simulated Factory that generates
synthetic data and exposes it over OPC
UA interfaces
we've also deployed an instance of a
Google's manufacturing data engine and
connected it to the simulated Factory
mte ingests harmonizes structures and
contextualizes the data from the factory
we have also set up an instance of
looker to visualize the data and enable
data exploration
using this foundational setup I will
demo two visualization scenarios one
real-time Factory visibility with a UI
ux optimized dashboards that allow the
simulated factory data to be visualized
as well as key kpis and insights to the
relevant user personas and second
integrated analytics that showcases how
easy it is to detect events in looker
the demo scenario is based on a
hypothetical company named motion PCB
Limited this company is a leading
manufacturer of rugged High reliability
printed circuit boards you can see one
of them at the top left motion pcbs
customers are mostly Automotive
suppliers who integrate they're
therefore quality longevity and overall
ruggedness of the pcbs are key selling
points for a company
motion PCB decided to embark on a
connected Factory journey to improve its
efficiency increase quality and
consistency
the company has three goals in the first
phase one it wants to ingest live
factory data two surface this data in
views and dashboards optimized for
various user personas and three analyze
events and Trends in that data
motion PCB starts the smart Factory
implementation with one of their main
assembly lines this assembly line has
three machines
one the stencil printer starts with an
empty Circuit with an empty Circuit
Board it deposits solder paste with high
Precision to prepare electric joints for
when the electric components are added
later
two the placement machine then adds
those components such as ICS commonly
referred to as chips the machine places
these directly onto the solder points
where the stencil printer already
deposited to solder paste before at this
stage the soldier paste is still liquid
and the components are not yet fixed
in the last step the Reflow oven exposes
the circuit board to a controlled
profile of heat which solidifies the
solder paste and creates a permanent
electric joint
at the end of the assembly line motion
PCB has installed a visual inspection
inspection quality control station this
station leverages Google's Coral TPU
modules to accelerate ml inferencing
this station was installed only a few
months ago
in this demo we have two personas with
different objectives
Carlos is motion pcb's Factory manager
he is looking for a clear understanding
of the factory status and seeing key
information at a glance
Carla started the connectors Factory
initiative and led the installation of
the visual inspection station
after discovering that quality
fluctuates he now doubled down on
connecting the rest of the factory to
see where those quality fluctuations are
coming from
Fatima is the maintenance engineer
responsible for keeping the assembly
line running she needs a more detailed
view of each machine and once to find
the root cause of problems to identify
the right fix
to help Carlos and Fatima do their job
motion PCB implemented a dashboard for
each of them
to show just the right information
let's start with Carlos the factory
manager
what you see here is the factory manager
dashboard that gives Carlos a high level
overview of his assembly line
in the upper part you'll see key
manufacturing kpis such as overall
equipment Effectiveness availability
yield quality and performance
the top right corner Services alerts to
make sure that Carlos's attention is
pointed to developing events early on
in the lower part of the dashboard
you'll see a visual representation of
the factory line along with Machine
level kpis
at the very bottom we surface quality
and performance As Time series data this
helps Carlos examine Trends very easily
currently the factories operating
normally producing pcbs at its expected
rate with average quality
besides the factory manager Carlos
there's Fatima the maintenance engineer
Fatima needs to have a more detailed
view of the factory to understand not
only if there are problems but also
where exactly they are coming from and
what root causes are driving them
to this end Fatima set up her own
dashboards without needing to write code
as our solution leverages looker Fatima
was able to configure the dashboard
simply using drag and drop
Fatima set up four dashboards for
herself the one here which gives her an
overview of the assembly line and three
detailed Machine level views
for example this style over here shows
detailed quality scores assigned to each
PCB produced this data is coming
directly from the visual inspection
module set up at the end of the assembly
line and the system can detect the work
quality of each of the three process
steps
next let's navigate to The Machine use
and start with a stencil printer finder
set up this page to give her key
information about the stencil printer at
the top she has the stencil printer's
key kpis
in the middle section Fatima picked a
Time series View for the printer's three
sensors temperature humidity and paste
flow rate
in our example these are the three most
relevant process parameters that
determine the quality of this process
step
finally in the equipment log you'll see
key log entries coming from this tensor
printer The Machine's messages are
arriving in an industry standard format
with a number of different types of
messages info messages include for
example order execution for which the
machine simply reports starting and
finishing work on a PCB unit in the log
here you see these arriving in real time
now let's see what happens if the
stencil printer experiences a failure to
do this I will open the simulator UI
switch on the first event and collapse
it back
let's also set the view to show the last
10 minutes only to zoom in on the most
recent developments
once done the dashboard refreshes and
then shows the data
okay now we notice a couple of things
first the flow rate is deteriorating
that's interesting
let's see if the machine reports any
relevant status messages by looking into
the event log below
here we notice that the low-level
process control system in the machine
detected that the flow rate is
abnormally low good to know
notice that Fatima doesn't have a Time
series dashboard set up for quality
versus flow rate however she'd like to
understand if the lower flow rate is a
cause for concern in terms of quality
this is where looker comes in it allows
Fatima to ask follow-up questions and
answer them herself very easily without
having to involve a data analyst a
programmer or anyone else for that
matter
to explore the relationship between
quality and flow rate Fatima simply
clicks explore from here from the flow
rate tile this brings up looper's
integrated explore view that allows her
to investigate any data
what you see here is a chart with the
average flow rate over time and a table
with the data below
let's add quality to it in the sidebar I
simply search for quality and click to
add it to the chart
last I click run to ask quicker to pull
the data from bigquery
as a result I see both flow rate and
quality in the same chart and really
there seems to be a strong correlation
quality has been stable but deteriorated
quickly after the flow rate went down
this puts Fatima on the right track in
her maintenance investigation
Fatima investigates the stencil printer
logs and determines that the stencil
printing head needs a replacement she
replaces the printing head and will
reflect that by switching off the
simulated event
returning to the office Fatima checks to
verify that the quality scores are
returning to normal
however as in any Factory there is
always something going on in motion
pcb's assembly line let's see what
happens when we switch on the second
event
okay so now we see an alert in the
dashboard something is wrong with the
placement machine so let's dig in I'll
first open the placement machine
dashboard
foreign
here we have an overview of key sensor
time series for the placement machine
One sensor measures the acceleration of
the placement mechanics as it moves
across the circuit boards to place the
chips
the other sensor on the right measures
background vibration as the machine is
highly sensitive to any excess
background vibration
we see that the background vibration has
been pretty high for the last few
minutes acceleration also looks a bit
unusual exceeding normal levels the log
also shows several event messages
produced by the machine which state that
it has trouble stabilizing the placement
mechanics Fatima heads out to the
factory floor arriving at the placement
machine she opens the maintenance view
for this alert but this particular error
hasn't been detected before and their
root cause is unclear after some digging
she notices that the power unit of the
machine is excessively loud and creates
a strong background hum luckily chanels
had repair the power unit and does it on
the spot
to reflect that let's switch off the
simulated event
foreign
s we observe the vibration values
returning to normal Fatima has done a
great job repairing the equipment
now back to Carlos in the office
Carlos is wondering if he can do
something about the oee numbers which
have some room for improvement
looking at the Quality scores for each
machine it becomes pretty clear that the
quality produced by the Reflow oven is
quite low this looks like a promising
opportunity to dig deeper Carlos asks
Spider-Man to investigate
let's look at the Reflow oven dashboard
to see if we can find anything that
could explain the problem
the machine reports no errors the lock
looks clean
so nothing obvious here
let's look at the sensor values if we
can see something
in PCB manufacturing the Reflow oven
needs to expose each circuit board to a
specific temperature curve to harden the
solder paste the only thing that stands
out here is that the peak temperatures
seem to vary slightly in their heights
housing over the chart it's clear some
Peaks are at 230 degrees Celsius some at
250 degrees Celsius but does this affect
quality and if yes which of the
temperatures produce better quality
let's go into explore mode to
investigate
first I will customize the chart to
focus on the most relevant information
to this end I'll remove the humidity
data series from the chart and I will
also set the time filter to the last 20
minutes
next I will add the average quality data
series to the report and click on run to
fetch the data
looking at this it's pretty obvious
higher Peak temperatures result in
better quality
seems like the Reflow oven is not able
to consistently create the right
temperature pattern
Fatima decides to involve the machine
OEM in this looker makes it easy to
share this view right from the screen by
clicking on the menu button then on send
I can share the report in various data
formats and over various channels for
example email let's send this to the
supplier and add a note
this helps shorten time to repair
sometimes dramatically by using data to
detect root causes quickly and remotely
in our scenario the supplier knows of a
bug in the oven control unit firmware
that can cause temperature patterns to
fluctuate the oven OEM rolls out an
update over the air to address the issue
to reflect that let's modify our
simulator
to see if quality improved Fatima
filters for the last 10 minutes and
refreshes the data and the quality
improvement is clearly visible this will
also drive up oee and Achieve Carlos's
objectives
well that's it for today's demo I hope
it gave you a good overview of the
virtually Limitless possibilities that
we can help unlock for our customers
[Music]